This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. For many years, tech companies have been really good at innovation and making money. What they've been less good at is in hiring and keeping a diverse workforce. In the past few months, Freakler reports of Silicon Valley's rocky relationship with women have bubbled to the surface. Very few women and non-Asian people of color in engineering. They're diversity or lack of diversity and what they plan on doing to tackle it. Many companies have gone to great lengths to study the problem and to address it. Google, for example, spends tens of millions of dollars every year on efforts to recruit
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。多年来，科技公司在创新和赚钱方面一直非常出色。但它们在招聘和留住多元化员工方面却表现平平。在过去的几个月里，关于硅谷与女性之间紧张关系的传闻浮出水面。工程部门中极少有女性和非亚裔有色人种。他们谈论多元化或缺乏多元化，以及他们计划如何解决这个问题。许多公司不遗余力地研究和解决这个问题。例如，谷歌每年花费数千万美元用于招聘
more women and people of color. Some of that money went to produce this video. Make it really clear, we want to see more women in senior leadership positions. We want to see more people from underrepresented groups because it makes us a better company. While there are recruitment success stories in Silicon Valley, the overall results have been dismal. Many women, African Americans and Latinos, see a tech is unwelcoming to them. Some have filed discrimination lawsuits against their companies. One senior software engineer at Google, James Deymor, recently suggested his company and the tech industry were going about it all wrong.
更多女性和有色人种。部分资金用于制作这段视频。非常明确的是，我们希望看到更多女性担任高级领导职务。我们希望看到来自代表性不足的群体的更多人，因为这使我们成为一家更好的公司。虽然硅谷有招聘成功的案例，但总体结果却令人沮丧。许多女性、非裔美国人和拉丁裔人认为科技行业对他们并不欢迎。一些人甚至对所在的公司提起歧视诉讼。谷歌的一位高级软件工程师詹姆斯·戴莫尔最近暗示，他的公司和科技行业在整个事情上都做错了。
In an internal memo, he argued that the vast gender gap in technology wasn't the result of prejudice, but of biological differences between men and women. Daymore cited research studies into the psychological and biological differences between the sexes. Women he said were more interested in people than things. They had more anxieties and lower stress tolerance. They tended to be less confrontational. This quality, he said, made it hard for them to ruffle feathers and take on leadership roles.
在一份内部备忘录中，他辩称，科技领域巨大的性别差距并非由偏见造成，而是由男女之间的生物学差异导致的。戴莫尔引用了关于两性心理和生物学差异的研究。他说，女性对人比对事物更感兴趣。她们有更多的焦虑和较低的压力承受能力。她们往往不那么具有对抗性。他说，这种特质使得她们很难打破常规并承担领导角色。
The memo created a firestorm inside the company. Many women at Google said it made them feel inferior and unwelcome. When that memo was leaked to the world, Google was not happy. Google has fired a software engineer who wrote a controversial internal memo that leaked over the weekend. He claimed that biology in part explained why there were more men than women in the tech field. Almost instantly, everyone seemed to have an opinion about the Google memo, the firing decision, and the larger question about women in tech. As far as I can see, they effectively have fired somebody for dissenting from the group consensus. The crux of his argument was that women were inherently less competent to hold high status
这份备忘录在公司内部引发了一场轩然大波。谷歌的许多女性表示，这让她们感到自卑和不受欢迎。当这份备忘录被泄露给全世界时，谷歌非常不高兴。谷歌解雇了一位软件工程师，他写了一份在周末泄露的充满争议的内部备忘录。他声称生物学在一定程度上解释了为什么科技领域的男性多于女性。几乎在一瞬间，每个人似乎都对谷歌的备忘录、解雇决定以及关于科技界女性的更大问题有了看法。据我所能看到的，他们实际上是解雇了一个背离群体共识的人。他论点的核心是，女性在本质上胜任高地位的
positions, which is a biased opinion. The infamous Google Memo, the most important document since the Magna Carta-Jay. Demor said the media took his statements out of context. His point he said wasn't to put down women or discourage them from entering tech. It was to find solutions to the technology gender gap by acknowledging the differences between men and women and seeking ways to bridge them. Science he said had conclusively found that nature, trumps nurture, that women and men are different, and all the diversity training in the world couldn't change that.
职位的能力较低，这是一种有偏见的观点。声名狼藉的谷歌备忘录，自《大宪章》以来最重要的文件——杰伊。戴莫尔表示，媒体断章取义了他的言论。他说，他的观点不是贬低女性或阻止她们进入科技行业，而是通过承认男女之间的差异并寻找弥合这些差异的方法，来寻找科技性别差距的解决方案。他说，科学已经无可辩驳地发现，天性胜过培育，男女是有差别的，世上所有的多元化培训都无法改变这一点。
If you have an opinion about De Mor, it probably comes in one of two flavors. You might say, of course he's right. Lots of scientists agree with him. Political correctness is keeping us from acknowledging the obvious. Or you may say, this is just the latest effort to use science to advance a racist or sexist agenda. It's no different than people who use spurious science in the 19th century to argue that blacks were slaves because they were inferior to whites.
如果你对戴莫尔有看法，它可能带有以下两种倾向之一。你可能会说，他当然是对的。很多科学家都同意他的观点。政治正确阻碍了我们承认显而易见的事实。或者你可能会说，这只是利用科学来推进种族主义或性别歧视议程的又一次尝试。这与19世纪利用虚假科学来争论黑人是奴隶因为他们不如白人劣等的做法没有什么不同。
This week on Hidden Brain, we ask how much the gender differences we see in the world can be explained by genes and chromosomes and how much the other result of culture and the environment. Noture? Gender identity really is largely socially learned. Versus nature? Socialization cannot override biology. Versus reality.
本周的《隐藏大脑》，我们探讨我们在世界上看到的性别差异有多少可以用基因和染色体来解释，又有多少是文化和环境的产物。天性？性别认同确实很大程度上是社会习得的。还是培育？社会化无法凌驾于生物学之上。还是现实。
The categories aren't even realistic and that was toxic to me because I could never fit into either one of those categories. You know, we're back to I was never able to make peace with being a male. And I know that I'm not a female as well. We're going to ask if this age-old debate really captures what we see in the world today. Is it possible the terms and categories of this debate are increasingly outdated? terms and categories of this debate are increasingly outdated? When the Google memo hit the news, the talk shows went hunting for experts. Let's go to our guest now.
这些分类甚至是不切实际的，这对我来说是有毒的，因为我永远无法契合这两个分类中的任何一个。你知道，我们回到了我从来无法与身为男性的自己达成和解。我也知道我不是女性。我们要问的是，这个陈旧的争论是否真正抓住了我们今天在世界上看到的情况？这种争论的术语和分类是否越来越过时了？这种争论的术语和分类是否越来越过时了？当谷歌备忘录成为新闻时，脱口秀节目开始四处寻找专家。现在让我们连线我们的嘉宾。
She is a writer about the intersection of science and sex and its politicization. She has a PhD in sexually-denurroscience from York University. And she has done quite a bit of work and research around this topic that we're going to get into with the Google memo. The one and only, Dr. Deborah So is here. Dr. So how are you? I'm well thanks, how are you Luke? Deborah So was in demand because like former Google engineer James Daymore, she is a firm
她是一位作家，研究科学与性别的交集及其政治化。她拥有约克大学的性神经科学博士学位。她围绕这个话题做了相当多的工作和研究，我们将与她探讨谷歌备忘录。独一无二的黛博拉·索博士就在这里。索博士，你好？我很好，谢谢，你呢，卢克？黛博拉·索之所以抢手，是因为像前谷歌工程师詹姆斯·戴莫尔一样，她坚信
believer that biology makes men and women different. Deborah has a PhD in neuroscience, but her opinions on gender are also personal. When we got in touch, she told me that when she was young, she did not feel much like a girl. All my friends were boys, I just as a boy, I looked like a boy. Deborah says she felt male. She has helped conduct studies into the nature of gender. She thinks both her outlook and her interest in science stem from her biology.
生物学造就了男女的不同。黛博拉拥有神经科学博士学位，但她对性别的看法也很个人化。当我们取得联系时，她告诉我，当她年轻时，她并不觉得自己很像个女孩。我所有的朋友都是男孩，我就像个男孩一样，我看起来像个男孩。黛博拉说她觉得自己是男性。她曾协助进行关于性别本质的研究。她认为她的人生观和对科学的兴趣都源于她的生物学特性。
I do think that I personally was exposed to higher levels of testosterone in the womb. Prenatal testosterone. That's Deborah's simple explanation for her boinness. The levels of exposure to prenatal testosterone is actually the determining factor in terms of what children will be interested in, what they will gravitate towards in terms of their interests and behaviors. In some ways, Deborah's point of view sounds pretty old-fashioned. Boys tend to gravitate towards mechanically interesting things, so they tend to be interested in things when they're playing with toys, they'll gravitate towards trucks and cars. Girls tend to be more interested in socially interesting activities, so things like playing
我确实认为我个人在子宫里接触到了更高水平的睾丸激素。产前睾丸激素。这就是黛博拉对她男孩子气的简单解释。接触产前睾丸激素的水平实际上是决定儿童会对什么感兴趣、在兴趣和行为上会倾向于什么的决定性因素。在某些方面，黛博拉的观点听起来相当过时。男孩倾向于被机械方面有趣的事物吸引，所以他们往往对事物感兴趣，当他们玩玩具时，他们会倾向于卡车和汽车。女孩往往对社会属性有趣的活动更感兴趣，比如玩
with dolls and playing house. Old-fashioned, right? But Deborah says the science backs her up with many studies. She gives one example of a research study on girls who have a genetic condition called congenital, adrenal, hyperplasia. These girls are exposed to unusually high levels of testosterone in the womb, and what we see when they are born is they will gravitate towards male typical toys. And this is even if their parents give them more praise for playing with female typical
娃娃和过家家。过时了，对吧？但黛博拉说，科学有很多研究支持她。她举了一个关于患有一种被称为先天性肾上腺皮质增生症的遗传疾病的女孩的研究例子。这些女孩在子宫里接触到异常高水平的睾丸激素，我们看到的是，当她们出生时，她们会倾向于男性典型玩具。即使她们的父母因为她们玩女性典型
toys. So it speaks to how powerful biology is, and that gender identity and gender preferences can't really be molded as much by socialization. Testosterone masculinizes the brain, Deborah says. You can see this play out in many ways. Men's brains on average are bigger than women's, and there are differences in the connective tissue in the brain's white matter. There are more connections running from the front
玩具而给予更多表扬，也是如此。因此，这说明了生物学的力量有多么强大，性别认同和性别偏好实际上不能被社会化塑造太多。黛博拉说，睾丸激素使大脑男性化。你可以看到这在很多方面体现出来。平均而言，男性的脑容量比女性大，并且大脑白质中的结缔组织存在差异。男性大脑中从前到后
to the back of the brain and men, and more connections running left to right or interhemisorically in women. So this leads to an adulthood differences. Well, I mean, this is evident from a very young age as well, in terms of what children gravitate naturally towards, differences in terms of efficiency of processing. So men tend to be more efficient on average
延伸的连接更多，而女性大脑中从左到右或半球间的连接更多。这导致了成年后的差异。嗯，我的意思是，从很小的年龄开始，这也是显而易见的，体现在儿童自然倾向于什么、处理效率的差异方面。因此，在视觉空间处理方面，
when it comes to visual spatial processing, whereas women tend to be more efficient with processing analytically and intuitively. In animals, researchers have observed behavioral changes after birth if testosterone levels are changed in utero. In the wild, male and female monkeys behave differently. Monkeys are not socialized to prefer certain toys over others. And we see the same thing with male monkeys they tend to gravitate towards trucks
男性平均而言往往效率更高，而女性在处理分析和直觉方面往往更有效率。在动物中，研究人员观察到，如果在子宫内改变睾丸激素水平，出生后会产生行为改变。在野外，雌雄猴子的行为表现不同。猴子没有被社会化以偏爱某些玩具而非其他玩具。我们看到雄性猴子也是如此，它们倾向于被卡车
and cars wield toys that boys tend to find more interesting. And we see the same thing with female monkeys they tend to gravitate towards more socially interesting toys like dolls. The bottom line says Deborah is that men and women are different. These differences are so obvious that she gets frustrated when people argue that gender is a social construct. To Deborah, that doesn't make sense. We look at it from an evolutionary perspective. We will, and I think people who take the socialization approach will agree,
和汽车等男孩往往觉得更有趣的玩具所吸引。我们看到雌性猴子也是如此，它们倾向于被像娃娃这样更有社交趣味的玩具所吸引。黛博拉说，底线是男女是不同的。这些差异是如此明显，以至于当人们争论性别是一种社会构建时，她会感到沮丧。对黛博拉来说，这说不通。我们从演化的角度来看待它。我们将——而且我认为采取社会化方法的人也会同意——
when we look at men and women on average, men tend to be taller than women, our reproductive organs are different. So they'll acknowledge and accept that there are these differences in terms of biology and physiology, but for some reason, those differences stop at the brain. And I don't think that makes much sense because when you look at the brain as an organ, it's responsible for these differences
当我们平均看待男女时，男性往往比女性高，我们的生殖器官是不同的。因此，他们会承认并接受生物学和生理学方面存在的这些差异，但出于某种原因，这些差异在大脑这里就停止了。我认为这没有什么道理，因为当你把大脑当作一个器官来看待时，它正是导致我们在器官和生长方面看到的这些
that we see with regards to organs and growth. Deborah wants to be clear, believing that biology shapes the choices men and women make does not mean she's sexist. Nora, she advocating lesser roles for women. In her view, these two things have nothing to do with each other. The scientific findings should be allowed to stand on their own. You know, if we acknowledge that men and women are different because this is what biology is telling us, that doesn't mean that they shouldn't be equal. It doesn't mean that one is necessarily better than the other. And I think also there's this sense that female typical traits are somehow inferior to male typical traits.
差异的原因。黛博拉想明确一点，相信生物学塑造了男女的选择并不意味着她是性别歧视者。她也没有主张女性扮演次要角色。在她看来，这两者没有任何关系。科学发现应该允许其独立存在。你知道，如果我们承认男女不同，因为这是生物学告诉我们的，这并不意味着他们不应该平等。这并不意味着一方必然比另一方更好。而且我认为人们也有一种感觉，即女性的典型特征在某种程度上不如男性的典型特征。
And I think that's the thing that we should be talking about. Why is that the case? Not pretending that women and men are absolutely identical. Not the only differences we see are due to socialization. In a sense, this is exactly the point that former Google software engineer James D. Moore was making. If you accept that men and women are biologically programmed to have different interests, then all the efforts to get more women to become engineers can look foolish.
我认为这是我们应该讨论的问题。为什么会这样？而不是假装男女完全相同。并非我们看到的唯一差异都是由于社会化造成的。从某种意义上说，这正是前谷歌软件工程师詹姆斯·戴莫尔所要表达的观点。如果你接受男女在生物学上被编程为具有不同的兴趣，那么所有让更多女性成为工程师的努力看起来就会很愚蠢。
But there's a problem with this view. When we look at the world, we have a tendency to think that the way the world is, is the way the world is supposed to be. Women are supposed to be. Women are supposed to be kind and affectionate. Men are supposed to be tough and dominant. Similar arguments to the ones that James and Debra are making were made a couple of generations ago to explain why Caucasians
但这种观点存在一个问题。当我们看待世界时，我们有一种倾向，认为世界的现状就是世界理应成为的现状。女性本该如此。女性本该是善良而深情的。男性本该是坚强而具有统治力的。詹姆斯和黛博拉所提出的类似观点，在几代人之前就被用来解释为什么高加索人
were smarter than Asians. There were very few Asians in American scientific institutions and very few Asian Nobel Prize winners, so it seemed reasonable to say that there was something about the biology of Asians that made them bad at science and tech. Today, we'd find that idea laughable. Again, because we see so many examples of Asians excelling at places like Google. If biology produces reality, how can that reality change dramatically in just a few decades?
比亚洲人更聪明。美国的科学机构中极少有亚洲人，亚洲诺贝尔奖得主也极少，因此当时似乎有理由认为亚洲人的生物学特性有什么问题，导致他们不擅长科学和技术。今天，社会大众会觉得这个想法荒谬可笑。同样是因为我们看到了太多亚洲人在谷歌等地表现卓越的例子。如果生物学产生了现实，这种现实怎么能在短短几十年内发生剧烈变化？
In a moment, we'll take a deeper look at the brain and what neuroscience can tell us about gender choices. But first, I want you to meet an historian. She thinks many of the choices that men and women and boys and girls make today are shaped by norms, by culture, even by marketing. I met Joe Peoletti at a mall in suburban Maryland. I'm a professor in American studies at the University of Maryland. Joe is also the author of the book, Pink and Blue, which explores the history of how we address our children.
稍后，我们将更深入地探讨大脑以及神经科学能告诉我们关于性别选择的什么信息。但首先，我想让大家认识一位历史学家。她认为今天男女和男孩女孩做出的许多选择是由规范、文化甚至市场营销塑造的。我在马里兰州郊区的一个商场里遇到了乔·佩奥莱蒂。我是马里兰大学美国研究教授。乔也是《粉红与蓝》一书的作者，该书探讨了我们如何为儿童着装的历史。
So I always had right for the infants department first to see how much pink there is and how many things you could put either a boy or girl in. The Children's Clothing Section at Macy's is packed with racks of onesies, dresses, and tiny suits for the under-seven set. It is, Joe told me, an excellent place for a history lesson. You know, one of my taglines that I'm going to put in my business card is I think deep thoughts about shallow things. It's what you do when you study popular culture. You can't just say, oh, I'm only going to study the intellectual stuff. Joe's been keeping tabs since the mid-1980s on gender norms by strolling through the clothing section of mainstream retailers. In recent years, she's noticed more gender neutral options for kids. But mainly she says, children's clothing remains predictable. Boys mostly wear the same palette of colors.
所以我总是径直走向婴儿区，看看有多少粉红色，以及有多少衣服可以给男孩或女孩穿。梅西百货的童装区塞满了各种连体衣、连衣裙以及为七岁以下儿童准备的小西装。乔告诉我，这是上历史课的好地方。你知道，我要印在名片上的一句座右铭是，我对浅显的事情做深刻的思考。这是你研究大众文化时所做的事。你不能只是说，哦，我只研究高深的东西。自20世纪80年代中期以来，乔通过在主流零售商的服装区闲逛，一直在关注性别规范。近年来，她注意到为儿童提供了更多性别中立的选择。但她主要表示，儿童服装依然是可以预见的。男孩们大多穿着相同的色系。
A lot of navy blue and olive and brown and black and gray. The boys' shirts, sweaters, jackets and pants have pictures of trucks, bulldozers, sports cars, and cute macho sayings. This goes even for infants. Joe points to a stack of onesies. There's dude, and we have a puppy, and we have an alien coming out of a pocket, as a matter of fact, the two out of the first four have little pockets, even though they're not functionally more, it's a pocket because he's a boy.
大量的海军蓝、橄榄绿、棕色、黑色和灰色。男孩的衬衫、毛衣、夹克和裤子上印有卡车、推土机、跑车和可爱的硬汉标语。婴儿也是如此。乔指着一叠连体衣。上面有“老兄（dude）”，我们有一只小狗，我们有一个从口袋里钻出来的外星人，事实上，前四个里面有两个有小口袋，尽管它们在功能上并没有多大用处，但它就是一个口袋，因为他是个男孩。
Little brother, super rad like dad, super hunk, local QDs. Next we head over to the girl section. It's overflowing with soft and cheerful hues. It used to be the pastels were kind of summer colors and now pastels are girl colors all year round. But if I'm looking at sort of things like this example, in the racks over here, it feels like there's absolutely no question that this is girls clothing. Well, it's very decorative. We have not only a flamingo, but a flamingo with flowers on it and a bow on its head so
小弟弟，像爸爸一样超级棒，超级帅哥，当地的QDs。接下来我们前往女孩区。这里洋溢着柔和愉悦的色调。过去，粉蜡色有点像夏季的颜色，而现在粉蜡色一年四季都是女孩的颜色。但如果我看着像这个例子这样的东西，在右边的这些衣架上，感觉毫无疑问这就是女孩的服装。嗯，它非常具有装饰性。我们不仅有一只火烈鸟，还有一只身上带着花朵、头上戴着蝴蝶结的火烈鸟，
you know it's a girl flamingo. Why do so many of us dress little boys and little girls so differently? It isn't biology. A hundred odd years ago, Joe says small kids were all dressed the same in rocks. And partly what it was was people really thought that drawing a child's attention to what their sex was was bad. That to the late 19th century, mine early 20th century, the cause of any kind of sexual depravity was precocious sexuality. Like a little girl should not be thinking in terms of being
所以你知道这是一只女孩火烈鸟。为什么我们这么多人把小男孩和小女孩打扮得如此不同？这不是生物学。乔说，一百多年前，小孩子都穿着裙子打扮得一模一样。部分原因在于，人们真的认为把孩子的注意力吸引到他们的性别上是不好的。在19世纪后期到
a woman someday, a little boy must not be thinking that he's like daddy until it's kind of developmentally appropriate. And back at that time, that developmental appropriateness was well past toddlerhood. So by the time they were four or five, a lot of the advice comes when the mothers are writing in the saying, when should I put my little boy in trousers? Because they'd be wearing little dresses.
20世纪初期，任何形式的性堕落的根源都被认为是过早的性意识。就像一个小女孩不应该想着有一天成为一个女人，一个小男孩直到发育上合适之前，绝不能认为自己像爸爸一样。而在那个时候，这种发育上的合适已经远远过了幼儿期。因此，当他们四五岁时，很多建议来自于母亲们的写信咨询，她们会问：“我什么时候应该给我小男孩穿上裤子？”因为他们一直穿着小裙子。
And he's tall for his age, or he's this, or he's that. And he say, well, you wait till he insists upon it. So, the idea that your gender was innate and you would start to express it later. But if you put children in, put a baby in pants, they would be, well, they'd be horrified at little girls in pants and the little boys in pants because pants were just not for babies. In the 1950s, many boys and girls were similar navy and moroun outfits to school. Play clothes were also dark.
而他个子长得高，或者他这样，或者他那样。人们会说，好吧，你得等到他自己坚持要穿。因此，你的性别是天生的，你会在后来开始表达它，这种想法在当时并不存在。但如果你把孩子们换上，给一个婴儿穿上裤子，他们会——嗯，他们会对穿裤子的小女孩和小男孩感到震惊，因为裤子根本不适合婴儿穿。在20世纪50年代，许多男孩和女孩上学时穿着相似的海军蓝和栗色服装。玩耍的衣服也是深色的。
Pastels were thought appropriate only for holidays like Easter or formal occasions. But gradually, the distinction between boys clothes and girls clothes started to grow. One reason, money. By the 1970s, American families were having fewer kids. Fewer kids meant families needed fewer clothes. For retailers, fewer clothes sold, meant fewer dollars. They didn't like that. So they came up with an ingenious way to sell more stuff. They marketed the idea that clothes defined what it was to be a boy or a girl.
粉蜡色被认为只适合复活节等节日或正式场合。但渐渐地，男孩衣服和女孩衣服之间的区别开始扩大。原因之一是金钱。到了20世纪70年代，美国家庭的孩子越来越少。孩子少意味着家庭需要的衣服也少。对于零售商来说，售出的衣服少意味着赚到的美元少。他们不喜欢这样。于是他们想出了一个巧妙的方法来卖出更多的东西。他们推销这样一种理念：衣服决定了什么是男孩或女孩。
The more you make something individual, the more you can sell. So having something that can only be worn by a girl means it can less likely be handed down to a brother. This led to a small bit of marketing genius. What we think of now is it's just a law, right, that pink is for girls and blue is for boys. That was invented too. If you make pink a girl's color and blue a boys color, then male and female siblings couldn't wear the same clothes. Marketing wasn't the only force at work. Societal biases came into play that allowed girls to sometimes wear blue, but made it hard for boys to ever wear pink.
你把某样东西变得越独特，你就越能卖出更多。因此，拥有某种只能由女孩穿的衣服，意味着它不太可能传给哥哥或弟弟。这带来了一点营销天才般的创新。我们现在认为这是理所当然的法则，对吧，粉红色是给女孩的，蓝色是给男孩的。这也是被发明出来的。如果你把粉红色定为女孩的颜色，蓝色定为男孩的颜色，那么兄弟姐妹就无法穿同一件衣服了。市场营销并不是唯一的驱动力。社会偏见开始发挥作用，允许女孩偶尔穿蓝色，但让男孩很难穿上粉红色。
A girl can wear blue. I look around and I see plenty of blue things and nobody says, she's wearing blue, she must be a boy or she's wearing blue, her mother must be making a statement about gender politics. But if a boy wears pink, there always has to be some kind of explanation. But if a boy wears pink, there always has to be some kind of explanation. Why is that? Because it goes back to the idea from the early unisex period in the 60s and 70s that it is better to be a boy than a girl. For a girl to want to be like a boy, that's understandable. And so go out of it. But for a boy to want to be like a girl, that's deviant and he must be taken to therapy. Or at least expect to be made the butt of jokes, like in this episode of Friends.
女孩可以穿蓝色。我环顾四周，看到到处都是蓝色物品，没有人会说，“她穿着蓝色，她一定是个男孩”或者“她穿着蓝色，她母亲一定是在对性别政治表态”。但如果一个男孩穿粉红色，就总得有某种解释。但如果一个男孩穿粉红色，就总得有某种解释。这是为什么呢？因为这可以追溯到60年代和70年代早期无性别时期的观点，即当男孩比当女孩更好。女孩想要像个男孩，那是可以理解的。所以长大了就好了。但对于一个男孩想要像个女孩，那是越轨的，他必须被送去接受治疗。或者至少要做好成为笑柄的心理准备，就像《老友记》里的这一集一样。
Does anyone see my shirt? It's a button down like a faded salmon color? You mean your pink shirt? Faded salmon color? No, I haven't seen your pink shirt? Faded salmon color? No, I haven't seen your pink shirt. Great, great. I must have left it at moan as I knew it. I'm sure you can get another one at Dan Taylor's.
有人看到我的衬衫吗？这是一件褪色三文鱼颜色的纽扣衬衫？你是说你的粉红衬衫？褪色三文鱼颜色？不，我没看到你的粉红衬衫？褪色三文鱼颜色？不，我没看到你的粉红衬衫。太棒了，太棒了。我一定把它落在莫娜那里了，我就知道。我确信你可以在丹·泰勒那里再买一件。
But seriously, what's interesting about Joe's point is it shows that what today might seem like individual gender choices are actually driven by many hidden factors. Money, marketing, homophobia, sexism. Does this mean that biology has no role in shaping what boys and girls and men and women do? It turns out the contention that genes and prenatal testosterone don't matter is as simplistic as saying they explain everything. Nature and nurture are completely intertwined Just as saying, they explain everything. Nature and nurture are completely intertwined, and there is no such thing as nature without
但说真的，乔的观点有趣的地方在于它表明，今天看起来像是个人性别选择的东西，实际上是由许多隐藏的因素驱动的。金钱、营销、恐同症、性别歧视。这是否意味着生物学在塑造男孩、女孩、男人和女人所做的事情上没有任何作用呢？事实证明，认为基因和产前睾丸激素不重要的争论，就像说它们能解释一切一样过于简单化了。天性和培育是完全交织在一起的，
nurture and vice versa. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're exploring today the differences between the sexes and the debate of where such differences come from. One thing that's not up for debate, an important part of how we understand people, is to ask if someone is male or female. This is why, when a baby is born, everyone wants to know.
就像说它们能解释一切一样过于简单化了。天性和培育是完全交织在一起的，没有没有培育的天性，反之亦然。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们今天正在探讨两性之间的差异以及这些差异来源的辩论。有一件事是没有争议的，即我们理解人类的一个重要部分，就是询问某人是男性还是女性。这就是为什么当婴儿出生时，每个人都想知道。
What is it? Gender is unquestionably the most salient feature of a person's identity. That's the first thing we notice about someone and it's certainly the first characteristic that infants learn to discriminate. This is Lisa Elliott. She's a professor of neuroscience at Roslyn Franklin University in Chicago. For some two decades, she's pondered and researched differences between boys and girls. Lisa, she first became interested in the subject as she was writing a book on brain development, but she became immersed in the topic after her own children were born. We had a daughter and a couple of sons and as many parents will tell you, they seem so different.
是个男孩还是女孩？毫无疑问，性别是个人身份中最显著的特征。这是我们对某人注意到的第一件事，也绝对是婴儿学会辨别的第一个特征。这是丽莎·埃利奥特。她是芝加哥罗莎琳·富兰克林大学的神经科学教授。大约二十年来，她一直在思考和研究男孩和女孩之间的差异。丽莎最初对这个主题产生兴趣是在她写一本关于大脑发育的书的时候，但在她自己的孩子出生后，她真正沉浸在这个主题中。我们生了一个女儿和几个儿子，正如许多父母会告诉你的那样，他们看起来太不一样了。
And that certainly is one of the favorite conversations among parents is gender differences. So I set out to do the research and really educate myself and translate to others what's truly known about the differences between boys and girls' brains. Lees didn't start by looking at boys' brains and girls' brains. She started with an insight about oil brains. More than any other organ, the brain is uniquely adaptable, designed to change in response to the environment. My own research has always been in the area of neuroplasticity,
这绝对是父母最喜欢谈论的话题之一，那就是性别差异。所以我着手进行研究，真正充实自己，并向其他人阐明关于男孩和女孩大脑差异的真正已知事实。丽莎并没有从研究男孩和女孩的大脑开始。她对所有大脑都有着深刻的见解。与其他任何器官相比，大脑具有独一无二的适应性，旨在响应环境而发生改变。我自己的研究一直集中在神经可塑性领域，
or how our brains change as a result of experience. And so I'm always sort of acutely aware of the fact that these little babies are absorbing things from the moment of birth. If you think of the brain not as a computer that comes with a chip and a hard drive, but more like a liquid designed to take the shape of the vessel that it's in, you start to get the idea. When a baby is born, its brain comes program not with the ability to learn one specific language, but to learn any language. The infant brain is designed to learn from everything that's going on around it. Much of that starts by being alert to the social world. It's remarkable the degree of understanding babies have way before they can talk, way
或者说我们的大脑如何因经历而改变。因此，我总是敏锐地意识到这样一个事实：这些小婴儿从出生那一刻起就在吸收各种事物。如果你不把大脑看作是一个自带芯片和硬盘的计算机，而是更像一种液体，旨在呈现它所处容器的形状，你就会开始领会到这一点。当婴儿出生时，它的大脑经过编程，不是为了学习一种特定的语言，而是为了学习任何语言。婴儿的大脑旨在从它周围发生的一切中学习。其中很大一部分始于对社会世界的警觉。婴儿在会说话之前、甚至在
before they can even reach out and grab a rattle under control. They appreciate the motives of other people. They can tell the difference between a good guy and a bad guy. And as I said, they can also discriminate gender and they start learning quite early the distinction between male and female, how their mother and father behave differently. So it's built in from the very get-go of social and communicative development. Although babies are unaware of their own gender, within the first few months of life they can tell the difference between male and female voices and male and female faces.
能够有意识地伸手去抓拨浪鼓之前，就拥有那种程度的理解力，这真是了不起。他们能体会其他人的动机。他们能分辨好人和坏人。正如我所说，他们还能辨别性别，并且很早就开始学习区分男性和女性，以及他们的父亲和母亲表现有何不同。因此，这是从社会和交际发展的最初阶段就内置进去了。尽管婴儿不知道自己的性别，但在生后的头几个月里，他们就能分辨出男声和女声、男性面孔和女性面孔。
They're absorbing clues to gender identity. Once children figure out they're a boy or girl which happens somewhere in the third year of life when they really have a solid understanding, it becomes a great crystallizer for their own behavioral decisions. Leeds doesn't dismiss the power of biology, but she thinks many of us fail to see what neuroscientists know. The brain not only is shaped, but has to be shaped by the social world.
他们正在吸收性别认同的线索。一旦孩子们弄清楚自己是男孩还是女孩——这发生在他们人生的大约第三年，当他们对此有了坚实的理解时——这就成了他们自己做出行为决策的一个巨大催化剂。利兹并没有抹杀生物学的力量，但她认为我们很多人未能看到神经科学家所知道的事实。大脑不仅被社会世界塑造，而且必须由社会世界塑造。
When we see differences between men and women and then see differences in their brains, we intuitively think, voila, this must explain why Johnny likes trucks and Jane likes dolls. But leaves believes the human brain is basically intersex or non-gendered with one major exception. Since men tend to be physically larger than women, the male brain is also likely to be larger than the female brain. You know, my view is, of course, there are group-level differences between men and women, but they're statistical, and they are not categorical.
当我们看到男女之间的差异，然后又看到他们大脑中的差异时，我们凭直觉会想：瞧，这一定解释了为什么约翰尼喜欢卡车而简喜欢娃娃。但利兹认为，人类的大脑基本上是双性同体的或无性别的，只有一个重大例外。由于男性的体型通常比女性大，因此男性的脑容量也可能比女性大。你知道，我的观点是，男女之间当然存在群体层面的差异，但它们是统计学上的，而不是绝对分类的。
So, whereas our reproductive organs come in two types. They come in testes or ovaries, and some other parts as well. Our brains come in one type, and it's a spectrum from masculinity to femininity. The male brain and female brain are no different than the male heart and the female heart than the male kidney and the female kidney, which by the way, also are all proportionally larger in men than women.
因此，尽管我们的生殖器官有两种类型。它们是睾丸或卵巢，还有其他一些部分。我们的大脑只有一种类型，它是一个从男性化到女性化的光谱。男性大脑和女性大脑与男性心脏和女性心脏、男性肾脏和女性肾脏没有什么不同，顺便说一句，这些器官在男性身上也按比例比女性更大。
Now, there used to be a time when scientists thought that the size of the brain was really important. Phrenologists measured the size and shapes of people's skulls and then drew sweeping conclusions about people from different groups. But more recent work has challenged the idea that bigger always means different. I've done several studies looking at structures that are alleged to differ between men and women. One is the hippocampus, which is important for memory, and the other is the amygdala,
曾几何时，科学家们认为大脑的大小非常重要。颅相学家测量人们头骨的大小和形状，然后对不同群体的人得出广泛的结论。但最近的工作对“更大总是意味着不同”这一观点提出了挑战。我做过几项研究，观察那些据称在男女之间存在差异的结构。一个是海马体，这对记忆很重要，另一个是杏仁核，
which is important for emotion and fear. And both of these structures have been alleged to differ between adult men and women, but when we did a meta analysis, basically downloading all of them dozens and dozens of studies of comparing men and women's brains, it turns out there is no difference between the hippocampus of men and women or the amygdala of men and women once you correct for overall brain size.
这对情绪和恐惧很重要。这两种结构都被认为在成年男女之间存在差异，但当我们进行元分析时——基本上是下载了所有几十项比较男女大脑的研究——结果证明，一旦你对整体大脑大小进行了校正，男女的海马体或男女的杏仁核之间就没有差异。
Lees agrees with Deborah So, the scientist we heard from earlier who believes that hormone levels in utero can affect the brain of the baby. But where Deborah sees hormonal influence as decisive, leaves things of it as just a nudge. There are probably some properties of toys that may appeal more to boys and girls, quote unquote,
利兹同意黛博拉·索的观点，即我们前面听到的那位相信子宫内激素水平会影响婴儿大脑的科学家。但黛博拉认为荷尔蒙的影响具有决定性，而利兹则认为这只是一种推动或微调。玩具可能有一些特性，能够“本能地”
instinctively. There's so much more layered on top of that in terms of the marketing, in terms of the parent and grandparent encouragement, in terms of the marketing, in terms of the parent and grandparent, you know, encouragement, in terms of especially peer reinforcement, because we see that there's almost no gender difference before the first birthday in the type of toys that children prefer. There's a little hint of it, maybe at about nine months, but it's really once children start to gender identify, and especially once they start breaking up into separate play groups, because gender segregation
更多地吸引男孩和女孩。在此基础之上，在营销方面、在父母和祖父母的鼓励方面、在营销方面、在父母和祖父母的鼓励方面，特别是同龄人的强化方面，还有更多层面的东西叠加在上面，因为我们看到在一岁生日前，儿童偏爱的玩具类型几乎没有性别差异。有一点迹象，也许在九个月左右，但真正当孩子们开始认同性别，特别是当他们开始分成不同的游戏小组时——因为性别隔离
happens beginning about age three, that the difference is in preference become extremely pronounced. So, there's a, I would say a strong social role, a modest innate or instinctive role, and you put those two together and you end up with a very dramatic divergence by the time kids are four years old. A host of scientific studies have found evidence of the powerful role that social influences play. There was this recent study out of Emory University where fathers were studying and they had these nice audio
从大约三岁开始发生——偏好的差异变得极其显著。因此，我可以说，这是一个强有力的社会角色，加上一个适度的先天或本能角色，你把这两者结合起来，当孩子们四岁时，就会导致非常巨大的分歧。大量科学研究发现了社会影响发挥强大作用的证据。埃默里大学最近有一项研究，研究对象是父亲们，他们配有精美的音频
recorders so the parents weren't aware of every moment, every interaction. And it turned out that the fathers were commenting more on their daughters' physical appearance, more on their tummies, and also endorsing their daughters' feelings more than their sons. Basically reacting more to their sons' neutral expressions and more to their daughters, sad or fearful expressions. And so we do this because we have different expectations for males and females, and that has to do with our very deep-seated gender assumptions. Lees also site to study with mothers and their 11-month-old babies. The infants are put on a, what looks like,
记录仪，因此父母并不清楚每一个时刻、每一次互动。结果发现，父亲们对女儿的外表发表更多评论，对她们的小肚子发表更多评论，而且比对儿子更能认可女儿的感受。基本上，他们对儿子中性表情的反应更多，而对女儿伤心或害怕表情的反应更多。所以我们这样做是因为我们对男女有不同的期望，这与我们根深蒂固的性别假设有关。利兹还提到了一项针对母亲及其11个月大婴儿的研究。婴儿被放在一个看起来
a crazy steep slope to crawl down, but it's carpeted and it has gating up on the sides, so it's safe. And it turns out when mothers were asked to adjust the steepness of the slope for the steepest slope they thought their babies were capable of crawling down, the mothers turned it to a steeper slope for their sons sons than their daughters and then when the infants were actually tested,
非常陡峭的斜坡上让他们往下爬，但铺了地毯，两边有护栏，所以是安全的。结果发现，当要求母亲们为她们认为婴儿有能力爬下去的最陡斜坡来调整斜坡的陡峭度时，母亲们为儿子设置的斜坡比女儿更陡；然而当婴儿实际接受测试时，
there was actually no difference in the courageousness or the physical ability of baby boys and girls to crawl down a steep slope. And yet another study, both mothers and fathers, discouraged risk-taking on the playground for their daughters more than for their sons. So when you start doing that, when kids are one and two and three years old, it really sets them on different trajectories. Without necessarily intending to treat sons and daughters differently, adults also subtly communicate expectations about language, math, and spatial skills.
男婴和女婴在勇敢程度或沿着陡峭斜坡爬下来的身体能力方面实际上没有任何差异。而在另一项研究中，父亲和母亲在游乐场上对女儿冒险行为的阻挠都比对儿子更多。所以当你开始这样做时，当孩子们一岁、两岁、三岁时，它确实让他们走上了不同的成长轨迹。成年人在不一定有意区别对待儿子和女儿的情况下，也会潜移默化地传达对语言、数学和空间技能的期望。
Research from Israel, for example, found that sixth grade teachers in Tel Aviv schools give girls slightly lower math scores than they deserve, and give boys slightly higher math scores than they deserve. By high school, the children often end up with different beliefs about their own ability in math. Males and females are both capable of learning spatial skills and verbal skills perfectly well. It really is largely a matter of dose of experience that determines our differences.
例如，来自以色列的研究发现，特拉华州特拉维夫学校的六年级老师给女孩的数学评分略低于她们应得的分数，给男孩的数学评分略高。到了高中，孩子们往往会对自己在数学方面的能力产生不同的信念。男性和女性都完全有能力学习好空间技能和语言技能。决定我们差异的，在很大程度上确实是经验剂量的多少。
Here's what all these studies together tell us. Social norms that treat girls and boys in different ways are all around us. And even the most diligent parents will find that they can control only a small fraction of the influences shaping their children. You cannot erase gender from a child's experience. There's no such thing as a gender-free society, and parents who claim that they're raising children gender-neutral. We treated our son and daughter exactly the same, are really fooling themselves.
所有这些研究共同告诉我们的是：以不同方式对待女孩和男孩的社会规范在我们周围无处不在。即使是最勤奋的父母也会发现，他们只能控制塑造自己孩子的种种影响中的一小部分。你无法从孩子的经历中抹去性别。世上根本没有所谓的无性别社会，那些声称自己在以性别中立的方式抚养孩子的父母——
Leigh says that doesn't mean people should stop trying to push back against gender stereotypes. What we can do is we can say what kind of society we do we want to have and what are the experiences that young children are immersed in that will either make boys and girls have more similarity of opportunity or will drive a wedge between them. And I think in our society we're always driving for greater equality. And so we need to think about how to maximize the brain potential of both genders as opposed
“我们对待儿子和女儿完全一样”——其实是在自欺欺人。利兹说，这并不意味着人们应该停止抵制性别刻板印象。我们能做的是，我们可以说我们想拥有一个什么样的社会，以及幼小的孩子沉浸在什么样的经历中，这些经历要么会让男孩和女孩有更多的机会相似，要么会在他们之间制造隔阂。我认为在我们的社会中，我们一直在争取更大的平等。因此，我们需要思考如何最大化两性的大脑潜力，而不是
to slot them into these limited roles that really don't allow them to express the full range of humanity. As I talk to scientists Lee Saliat and Deborah Soe and to historian Joe Peoletti, I realize that all of them agreed on one thing. People ought to be allowed to live their lives, to be all they want to be, regardless of what the world tells them they should be. To what the end of his memo on gender issues, Google Engineer James Daymore said, I hope it's clear that I'm not saying that diversity is bad, that we shouldn't try to correct
将他们塞进这些限制性的角色中，使他们无法表达人性的全部丰富性。当我与科学家利兹·埃利奥特、黛博拉·索以及历史学家乔·佩奥莱蒂交谈时，我意识到他们都在一件事上达成了一致。无论世界告诉他们应该成为什么样的人，人们都应该被允许过自己的生活，成为他们想成为的一切。在关于性别问题的备忘录的结尾，谷歌工程师詹姆斯·戴莫尔说：“我希望很清楚，我并不是说多元化是不好的，我们不应该试图纠正
for existing biases, or that minorities have the same experience of those in the majority. I'm also not saying that we should restrict people to certain gender roles, I'm advocating for quite the opposite. Treat people as individuals, not as just another member of their group. The person we're going to hear from next has never talked to James Daymore or Deborah Soh, never taken a class with Joe Peo Lady or Lee Sallien. But I'm sure I know what this person, Jimmy Shoop, would say to the idea that we should treat people as individuals, and not as just another member of their group.
现有的偏见，或者说少数群体与多数群体的经历相同。我也没有说我们应该把人们限制在某些性别角色中，我主张恰恰相反。把人当作个体对待，而不仅仅是他们群体的又一个成员。”我们接下来要听到的人从未与詹姆斯·戴莫尔或黛博拉·索交谈过，从未上过乔·佩奥莱蒂或利兹·埃利奥特的课。但我确信我知道这个人——杰米·舒普——会对“我们应该把人当作个体对待，而不仅仅是他们群体的又一个成员”这一观点说些什么。
The reason I went to court to blow all of this up was we're all unique human beings and I think we're a mixture to some extent of male and female, you know, irrespective of the biology. When we come back, what Jamie Shoupe, the first legally recognized, non-binary person in the United States, Can tell us about the great gender debate. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We've been talking today about gender and about our long-running debates over the role of biology versus culture. For many years,
我之所以诉诸法庭来彻底打破这一切，是因为我们都是独特的人类，我认为我们在某种程度上是男性和女性的结合体，无论生物学如何。稍后回来，美国首位获得法律承认的非二元性别者杰米·舒普将告诉我们关于伟大性别辩论的什么。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们今天一直在讨论性别，以及关于生物学与文化作用的长期辩论。多年来，
these debates have largely assumed that gender is a binary, male and female. But even in science struggles to understand the male brain and the female brain, some people are challenging the reality of those fundamental categories. Jamie Shoop is in the vanguard of that movement. Jamie just pulled into Carson City, Nevada, after roaming around the West for the past few months, in a small camper, perched on top of a pickup truck. So basically we're in what's called a truck camper. It's approximately 17 feet long.
这些争论在很大程度上一直假定性别是一个二元对立的概念，即男性和女性。但即使科学界也在努力理解男性大脑和女性大脑的区别，而有些人则在挑战这些基本分类的现实性。杰米·舒普（Jamie Shoop）正是这场运动的先锋。在过去几个月里，杰米驾驶着一辆装在皮卡车顶上的小型露营车，在西部各地四处游历，刚刚抵达内华达州的卡森城。所以基本上我们住的是所谓的卡车露营车。它大约有17英尺长。
It weighs about around 3,000 pounds. In other words, heavy and small but also efficient. I've got a microwave and oven stove, you know, double sink, a small bathroom with a shower. Jamie's at ease in this desert town, clad in jeans, a flowing blouse and head scarf. The camper has been traveling a lot of late, but for now, Jamie's biggest journey is over. ease in this desert town, clad in jeans, of flowing blouse and headscarf. The campers been traveling a lot of late, but for now, Jamie's biggest journey is over, a rocky trip over the landscape of gender identity. I think the best way to frame this and understand it
它重大约3000磅。换句话说，既重又小，但也很高效。我有一个微波炉和烤箱炉灶，你知道的，双水槽，还有一个带淋浴的小浴室。杰米在这个沙漠小镇里显得很悠闲，身穿牛仔裤、飘逸的衬衫和头巾。这辆露营车最近一直在四处奔波，但就目前而言，杰米的最大旅程已经结束——在这沙漠小镇中显得很悠闲，身穿牛仔裤、飘逸的衬衫和头巾。这辆露营车最近一直在四处奔波，但就目前而言，杰米的最大旅程已经结束了，这是一段跨越性别认同地貌的坎坷旅程。我认为构架和理解这一点最好的方式
is to just think of me as very fluid. Jamie lives between the sexes. Jamie thinks not of himself or of herself, but of themselves. I can be masculine, I can be feminine, I can do anything I want. Jamie is the first officially recognized non-gendered person in America. It was a status that had to be fought for and won. It came after a five-decade struggle, a struggle to find an identity that felt right. Now 54 years old, Jamie was born in Washington, DC and raised in a large blue collar family
就是把我视为非常流动的人。杰米生活在两个性别之间。杰米想到的既不是他自己，也不是她自己，而是“他们”（they）。我可以是阳刚的，我可以是阴柔的，我可以做任何我想做的事。杰米是美国第一位官方认定的无性别者。这是一个必须通过抗争才能争取并赢得的身份。这是在经历了长达五十年的挣扎之后才实现的，这是一场寻找感觉正确的身份的挣扎。现年54岁的杰米出生在华盛顿特区，在马里兰州南部乡村的一个大型蓝领家庭中长大
in rural southern Maryland. It was a place of tobacco farms and deep conservative views. This is a place where the black kids that I cut tobacco with during the summer, they weren't allowed in the farmer's houses because they were black. I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, like putting, I remember one occasion I'd read an article about putting mayonnaise and egg in your hair to make it soft and my mother absolutely just went ballistic over that and slapped me and called me a sissy. Jamie's mother also lost it when the teenager refused to get a short haircut and instead got a perm. I just wanted to feel more feminine. So this was Jamie's dilemma.
那是一个烟草农场遍布、保守观念根深蒂固的地方。这是一个夏天和我一起割烟草的黑人孩子不能进农民家里的地方，因为他们是黑人。我的意思是……比如说，我记得有一次我读到一篇文章，说把蛋黄酱和鸡蛋抹在头发上可以让头发变软，我妈妈对此简直大发雷霆，狠狠地扇了我一巴掌，还骂我是娘娘腔。当这个十几岁少年拒绝剪短发而是去烫发时，杰米的母亲也崩溃了。我只是想感觉更女性化一点。所以这就是杰米的困境。
He had a male body, but inside there was also a she, with all this femininity flowing about. Romantically, Jamie was drawn to both boys and girls, but this was the late 1970s, so Jamie took a girl to the Queen of Hearts Dance and drove a big wheel Camaro and cut Tobacco and felt nothing at all like a real boy. Yeah, I mean, I just, I've never been connected to identifying as a male. I've never agreed that I was a male.
他拥有男性的身体，但内心也住着一个“她”，身上流淌着所有的女性特质。在感情上，杰米同时被男孩和女孩吸引，但那是20世纪70年代末，所以杰米带了一个女孩去参加红心女王舞会，开着一辆大轮卡迈罗跑车，割过烟草，却完全不觉得自己像个真正的男孩。是的，我的意思是，我从来没有觉得自己认同为男性。我从未同意过自己是个男性。
And yeah, I just had, I had no connection to, to masculinity. But you know, at the same time I knew what the boundaries were and I knew what the punishment was and I just kind of went along with things. After high school, with no money and few options, Jamie entered the army, trained as a mechanic. It meant more going along with things. You know, the military is a world of testosterone and diesel fuel and I don't relate to all that. But the younger crew was brilliant at fixing things. Soon a promotion came.
而且是的，我就是对男性特质没有任何认同感。但你知道，与此同时我知道界限在哪里，我也知道惩罚是什么，所以我基本上就是顺从了这一切。高中毕业后，由于身无分文且选择有限，杰米参军了，并接受了机械师培训。这意味着更多地顺从现状。你知道，军队是一个充满雄性激素和柴油味的世界，而我对这一切都没有共鸣。但这位年轻的船员在修理东西方面非常出色。不久，晋升就来了。
Jamie made Supervisor. I was a computer whiz, so they made me an information system security officer. I was the go-to person to write awards and write evaluation reports. Yes, and I was highly intelligent about how to fix the vehicles. I could walk into the shop and say, well, this is what we need to do to fix this. So all those things, you know, they cover it up for my gender, variances, and my sexual orientation. But other soldiers picked up that Jamie was different.
杰米当上了主管。我是一个电脑奇才，所以他们让我担任信息系统安全官。我是专门负责撰写嘉奖令和评估报告的人。是的，而且我在如何修理车辆方面非常有智慧。我可以走进车间说，嗯，这就是我们需要做的修理方案。所以所有这些事情，你知道，它们掩盖了我的性别差异和我的性取向。但其他士兵还是察觉到杰米与众不同。
It led to some scary situations. Once at a training site, Jamie was surrounded by several officers and the instructor. And they started scribing sex acts between males, and they were just getting really vulgar, and they were doing it entirely for my benefit. They were saying all these things, and looking at me the whole time,
这导致了一些可怕的情况。有一次在一个训练基地，杰米被几个军官和教官包围了。他们开始描述男性之间的性行为，而且言语非常粗俗，他们完全是当着我的面故意这么做的。他们说着所有这些话，全程一直看着我，
and just studying to see what my reaction would be. What was your reaction? I was terrified. This was Jamie's life for 18 years. Walking the finest of lines, fearing that one wrong step might result in an attack or the end of a hard-earned career in the army. It's a sad story, but through much of it, Jamie had one powerful source of support. My name is Sandy at Shoeop. So I've married to Jamie. We've been married about 30 years now. We have one child. Jamie and Sandy sit side by side as they talk about their life.
只是在观察我的反应会是什么。你的反应是什么？我吓坏了。这就是杰米长达18年的生活。如履薄冰，生怕一步走错就会遭到攻击，或者结束在军队中来之不易的职业生涯。这是一个悲伤的故事，但在其中的大部分时间里，杰米有一个强大的支持源泉。我叫桑迪·舒普（Sandy Shoop）。我和杰米结婚了。我们已经结婚大约30年了。我们有一个孩子。杰米和桑迪并肩坐在一起谈论他们的生活。
They're in a small park across the street from an RV campground under the shade of a picnic shelter. They see them at ease. Sandy grew up outside Fort Knox, Kentucky. She met Jamie when a friend set them up on a blind double date. The guys didn't have cars. So my friend Tina, we picked up the guys on base, and so when we went to pick them up,
他们坐在房车露营地对面街区的一个小公园里，在一处野餐棚的阴凉下。他们看起来很放松。桑迪在肯塔基州诺克斯堡郊外长大。经朋友撮合，她在一次盲目的双人约会上遇到了杰米。当时那些小伙子们没有车。所以我和朋友蒂娜去基地接了那些小伙子们，当我们去接他们的时候，
I said it was really kind of the first time I'd seen Jamie, and I'm like, I pulled my friend aside because we were going up to a bar up in Louisville. And I'm like, are they old enough to get into the bars? Because Jamie had such a baby face. But Jamie also had an enduring personality. They hit it off. Sandy liked how sweet and attentive Jamie was, so different from other guys she did it.
我说这真的是我第一次见到杰米，我当时就把朋友拉到一边，因为我们正准备去路易斯维尔的一家酒吧。我说：他们达到进入酒吧的年龄了吗？因为杰米长着一张娃娃脸。但杰米也有一种持久的个性。他们一拍即合。桑迪喜欢杰米的温柔和体贴，这与其他她约会过的男生截然不同。
They had fun together. One thing Sandy didn't notice was Jamie's gender struggles. They were clues, but Sandy shrugged them off. There was like, sometimes Jamie would just kind of strange. Like Jamie had to have this leopard print, kind of like, you know, t-shirt, kind of, not, you know, it was like sleeveless, but it was like this leopard print.
他们在一起很开心。桑迪没有注意到的一点是杰米的性别挣扎。其实有迹象，但桑迪没有放在心上。比如，有时杰米会显得有点奇怪。就像杰米必须穿那种豹纹的，你知道的，T恤之类的，不是那种，你知道的，它是无袖的，但就是这种豹纹的。
And it's not something you would normally see on a guy. And that was just kind of like, hmm, you know, but I just put it down as, you know, when I, Jamie's quirk, you know, I mean, I was frunken, Tucky, and you know, it's the south, and I was like, well, okay, well, Jamie's not from around here, so. So, we eventually got married.
这不是你在一个男人身上通常会看到的。这给我的感觉有点像，嗯，你知道的，但我只是把它归结为，你知道的，杰米的怪癖，你知道的，我的意思是，我来自肯塔基州，你知道的，那是南方，我当时想，好吧，好吧，杰米不是本地人，所以。所以，我们最终结婚了。
A few years later, while stationed at Fort Hood, Texas, they had a daughter. She's an awesome kid. And when Jamie talks about getting grief from colleagues in the military, did you hear about that? I'm wondering if these issues of gender and sexuality came up in your conversations. No, Jamie really didn't discuss that kind of stuff.
几年后，当驻扎在德克萨斯州胡德堡时，他们有了一个女儿。她是个极好的孩子。当杰米谈到在军队中受到同事的刁难时——你听说过这件事吗？我想知道性别和性取向这些问题是否在你们的对话中出现过。没有，杰米真的没有讨论过那种事情。
He had Jamie would grumble about the things like work issues and stuff like that. But I really don't remember Jamie talking about anything like that. Jamie, I guess, kept it close to the vest, it would be an expression to use. But yeah, I don't remember. But the truth is, Jamie's carefully choreographed life was coming apart. There were run-ins with supervisors who suspected Jamie was gay.
他会，杰米会抱怨一些事情，比如工作上的问题诸如此类的事情。但我真的不记得杰米谈论过任何类似的话题。我想杰米一直对这些守口如瓶，用这个词来形容很贴切。但是是的，我不记得了。但事实是，杰米精心编排的生活正在瓦解。他开始与那些怀疑杰米是同性恋的主管发生冲突。
One said he wasn't going to recommend Jamie for any promotions, despite his teller work record. It was like being confined in a cell where the walls kept closing in. And then, one icy winter morning, Jamie fell and broke a wrist during a training run. The injury caused permanent damage. After 18 years, Jamie's army career was over.
其中一人说，尽管杰米的工作记录无可挑剔，但他不会推荐杰米晋升。这就像是被关在一个四面墙壁不断向内挤压的牢房里。然后，在一个冰冷的冬日早晨，杰米在一次训练跑步中摔倒并骨折了手腕。这次受伤造成了永久性损伤。18年后，杰米的军旅生涯结束了。
After getting medically discharged, Jamie's gender crisis intensified. I was 49 years old. I think it's best to term it as I was at my breaking point. I had literally had nearly five decades of suppressing my gender identity, suppressing my sexual orientation. And it was really, literally to the point of like, I mean, I was kind of thinking either I do something about this or I commit suicide. I mean, it had reached that level of distress. The choice was that stark.
在经过医学退伍后，杰米的性别危机加剧了。我当时49岁。我认为最好用“我到了崩溃的边缘”来形容。字面意思上，我有将近五十年的时间一直在压抑自己的性别认同，压抑自己的性取向。那种感觉真的、字面意义上达到了这样的程度：要么我得为之做点什么，要么我就去自杀。我的意思是，那种痛苦已经达到了那个程度。抉择就是如此严峻。
And it's the point in our story when you might expect a familiar resolution. In this version of the story, Jamie stops hiding and comes out as a woman. Maybe gets gender reassignment surgery. That was indeed the path that Jamie's doctors initially recommended. And for a time, Jamie eagerly listened to them. So I bought into it, I'll climb and sink her in, right away decided I was gonna transition to a female because I expected it to help alleviate
这也是我们故事中你可能会期待一个熟悉结局的节点。在这个版本的叙事中，杰米不再隐藏，而是出柜成为一名女性。也许还会去做性别重置手术。这确实是杰米最初的医生们推荐的道路。有一段时间，杰米急切地听从了他们的建议。所以我接受了，我全盘接受了，立刻决定我要过渡为女性，因为我期望这能有助于缓解
by mental health crisis that I was having from all the suppression. Jamie also finally told Sandy what was going on. It was kind of a surprise, but I mean, I wasn't offended. I was just kind of like, you know, when you marry someone, it's because you love them. And you want them to be happy and you want them to, you know, be fulfilled. And I just, I want Jamie to be happy.
由于长期的压抑而引发的心理健康危机。杰米最终也将发生的事情告诉了桑迪。这有点出乎意料，但我的意思是，我并没有被冒犯。我当时的心态大概是，你知道的，当你和一个人结婚，那是因为你爱他。你希望他快乐，你希望他，你知道的，能够实现自我价值，而我只是希望杰米快乐。
It's not that Sandy would have chosen this route. She says, of course she would have liked to live life with Jamie as a he. But in a way she says, this is what she signed up for when she married a soldier. You know, Jamie really feels that this is something that they have to do. And, you know, I've always supported Jamie. I mean, you know, as an army wife and, you know, that was your part of your job. You know, you were just like, you were the support. You were the one that, you know, to care of things like for the soldiers.
倒不是说桑迪会主动选择这条路。她说，当然她会愿意和作为男性的杰米一起生活。但在某种程度上她说，这就是她嫁给一个军人时所承诺接受的。你知道，杰米真的觉得这是他们必须去做的事情。而且，你知道的，我一直支持杰米。我的意思是，你知道的，作为一名军嫂，你知道的，那是你职责的一部分。你知道，你就像是，你就是后盾。你就是那个去，你知道的，照顾士兵相关事务的人。
So with Sandy's support, Jamie started taking hormones, developing breasts, wearing awake and high heels, and hanging out with transgender women. But it still didn't feel right. After hearing a few horror stories about gender reassignment surgeries that turned out poorly, Jamie rejected that option. Also, Jamie didn't want to wear clothes that screamed female. And my idea of transitioning was, okay, so I'll start wearing women's jeans, I'll wear women's casual shirts, I'll probably put a flowered scarf on my head or something like that.
因此在桑迪的支持下，杰米开始注射激素、发育乳房、戴假发穿高跟鞋，并与跨性别女性交往。但感觉仍然不对劲。在听到一些关于性别重置手术结果糟糕的恐怖故事后，杰米拒绝了那个选项。此外，杰米不想穿那些大声宣告自己是女性的衣服。而我当时对性别转变的想法是，好吧，那我开始穿女式牛仔裤，穿女式休闲衬衫，我可能会在头上戴一条印花头巾或类似的东西。
And in the trans women, I was interacting with them, they were absolutely freaking over that. They were like, well, you don't look like a female, we don't want to hang out with you, because I wasn't doing enough to be hyper feminine. Here's what Jamie was realizing. There were rules about what it meant to be a woman, or gay, or trans. The transgender community has hierarchies. You never see cross-dressers in the news.
而在我接触的跨性别女性群体中，她们对此反应绝对抓狂。她们会说，嗯，你看起来不像女性，我们不想跟你混在一起，因为我没有付出足够多的努力来变得超级女性化。杰米当时意识到的是这些：关于成为女性、同性恋或跨性别者，存在着各种规则。跨性别社群内部也有等级制度。你从在新闻里看到过跨性别异装癖者吗？
It's all about the trans women and the trans men. And the lesbian community, they have their gold star or lesbians that if you've ever touched a male, then you're not really a lesbian, you're not our equal. Yeah, everywhere you look in society, there's hierarchies. Jamie didn't like this. Jamie didn't feel like a woman trapped inside a man's body. Jamie felt like a man and a woman.
全都是关于跨性别女性和跨性别男性的新闻。而在女同性恋社群里，她们有自己的“金星”或诸如此类的女同性恋标准——如果你曾经碰过男性，那么你就不算是真正的女同性恋，你就不配与我们平等。是的，无论你在社会何处环顾，到处都存在着等级制度。杰米不喜欢这样。杰米并不觉得自己是一个被困在男性身体里的女性。杰米觉得自己既是男性也是女性。
Why couldn't Jamie just be Jamie? You know, I said it was all very black and white thinking that you know you're either male or your female and if you're a female, you know, this is this pathway that you do to become a female. If Jamie went to the doctor and said I think I'm female and the doctor asked why, Jamie might say because I do feminine things. As a kid I played hopsc female and the doctor asked why, Jamie might say, because I do feminine things. As a kid, I played hopscotch and jacks and permed my hair and hated football. I feel more comfortable among girls than boys.
为什么杰米不能仅仅做杰米自己呢？你知道的，我说过这全都是非黑即白的思维，认为你要么是男性，要么是女性；如果你是女性，你知道的，这就是你成为女性所要遵循的途径。如果杰米去找医生说“我觉得我是女性”，而医生问为什么，杰米可能会回答：因为我做女性化做的事。小时候我玩跳房子和抓子儿，烫头发，讨厌橄榄球。相比男孩，我在女孩中间感觉更舒适。
And the doctor's might tell Jamie, you're really a woman and you can transition to being female. But if Jamie had gone to the doctor and said, I think I'm female because I like women and fast cars and tinkering with machines. The doctor might say, I don't really think your chance. But why not? As I talk to Jamie, I realize that the answer
医生可能会告诉杰米，你真的是个女人，你可以过渡成为女性。但如果杰米去找医生说，我觉得我是女性是因为我喜欢女人、跑车和摆弄机械。医生可能会说，我觉得你并不符合。但为什么不呢？在与杰米交谈时，我意识到答案
is that most of our conceptions of gender are built around a series of stereotypes of what it means to be a man or a woman. My question and the reason I went to court to blow all of this up was, you know, we're all unique human beings and I think we're a mixture to some extent of male and female, you know, irrespective of the biology. So here's what happened. Once Jamie made peace with this idea that the categories of male and female were too confining,
在于，我们对性别的绝大多数概念都是围绕着一系列关于成为男人或女人意味着什么的刻板印象构建起来的。我的问题以及我走上法庭去打破这一切的原因是，你知道的，我们都是独特的个体，我认为在某种程度上，无论生物学如何，我们都是男性和女性的混合体。事情是这样的：一旦杰米接受了“男性和女性的分类过于局限”这一想法，
Jamie wanted legal documents to reflect this point of view. Jamie didn't want to be a he or a she, but a they. Jamie's Oregon State ID card said female. Jamie wanted that changed. Well, the first stop was actually the DMV in downtown Portland. I walked in there one day and I told the clerk, I said I want you to remove either. I had female on my organ ID and I said I want you to remove the female off of there and I don't want you putting male on there.
杰米就希望法律文件能够反映这一观点。杰米不想成为“他”或“她”，而是“他们”（they）。杰米俄勒冈州的州身份证上写的是“女性”。杰米想要改变这一点。嗯，第一站实际上是波特兰市中心的机动车辆管理局（DMV）。有一天我走进去，对办事员说，我要求你移除其中一项。我的俄勒冈州身份证上写着女性，我说我要求把上面的女性去掉，我也不要你在上面填男性。
I want nothing on there. The answer Jamie received wasn't a big surprise. And she just, you know, calmly and politely says, well, we don't do that. At that point, you know, her denial of taking the gender marker off of my ID gave me an actionable legal claim. And I went and started searching for attorneys. Jamie found a Portland attorney who agreed to take on the case.
我什么也不要留在上面。杰米得到的回答并不算出人意料。她只是，你知道的，平静而有礼貌地说，嗯，我们不这样做。在那一刻，你知道的，她拒绝从我的身份证上移除性别标记的行为，给了我一个可诉的法律主张。于是我开始寻找律师。杰米在波特兰找到了一位同意接手这个案子的律师。
What did you ask him to do? I literally told him I wanted to be declared for attorneys. Jimmy found a Portland attorney who agreed to take on the case. What did you ask him to do? I literally told him I wanted to be declared non-binary as my sex, which would mean that I was neither male or female. What was his strategy? It's unbelievably simple. Jimmy's attorney downloaded a readily available status shoot sex change form.
你让他做什么？我字面意思地告诉他，我想被宣告为律师。杰米找到了一位同意接手此案的波特兰律师。你要求他做什么？我直截了当地告诉他，我要求将我的性别宣告为非二元性别，这意味着我既不是男性也不是女性。他的策略是什么？简单得令人难以置信。杰米的律师下载了一份现成的变性申请表。
He put it into the computer. He took Photoshop and he did, you know, he cut out where it said male and female and he typed in non-binary and he filed it with a court. That was it. A court date was set for June of 2016. Jamie made sure to be ready. I came armed with two letters from the doctors, you know, one from the VA and one from
他把它输入电脑。他用Photoshop进行了处理，你知道的，他把写着男性和女性的地方裁剪掉，然后打上了“非二元性别”，并将其提交给法院。就是这样。庭审日期定于2016年6月。杰米确保自己做好了准备。我带着医生的两封信武装前往，你知道的，一封来自退伍军人事务部（VA），一封来自
OHSU saying that the doctors supported the change. We walked into court. I mean, the judge hardly said anything and signed it. With that pens truck, Jamie's shoe became the first person in America to be legally declared as neither male nor female. A half century of struggle was over. I was on a different planet. I mean, I was just kind of speechless. It was just a very surreal moment.
俄勒冈健康与科学大学（OHSU），上面写着医生支持这一更改。我们走进了法庭。我的意思是，法官几乎什么也没说就签字了。随着那笔一挥，杰米·舒up成为了美国第一个在法律上被宣告既不是男性也不是女性的人。半个世纪的抗争结束了。我仿佛置身于另一个星球。我的意思是，我当时简直说不出话来。那是一个非常超现实的时刻。
It was kind of like the judge said, yes. And I was in a days. We walked through the courthouse courthouse and next thing I know I was crying on the sidewalk. The judge's decision legitimizing Jamie's gender fluidity meant all the constraints were gone. No more hiding, no more URA or B, no more if you're a this then you have to behave like that. Water says Jamie, that's what life feels like now. It just flows. I really like my place now of being non-binary because I have had all the roles stripped away from me.
就像法官说“行”一样。而我当时处于一种恍惚状态。我们走过法院大厅，等我回过神来时，我已经在人行道上哭泣了。法官的决定使杰米的性别流动性合法化，这意味着所有的束缚都消失了。不再有隐藏，不再有这样或那样，不再有“如果你是这种人，你就必须那样表现”。水流般的杰米，这就是现在生活给人的感觉。它只是在流动。我真的很喜欢现在这种非二元身份的处境，因为我身上所有的角色都被剥离掉了。
You know, you can't tell me that I'm in the wrong clothing. You can't tell me that I'm loving the wrong person. You know, I can be masculine, I can be feminine, I can do anything I want. I've broken all the rules and just gotten rid of them. Jamie wants to roam. That's the appeal of being non-binary and also the attraction of traveling around in the camper. Yeah, we went from the 3,000 square foot
你知道的，你不能对我说我穿错了衣服。你不能对我说我爱错了人。你知道的，我可以是阳刚的，我可以是阴柔的，我可以做任何我想做的事。我已经打破了所有的规则，把它们统统抛诸脑后。杰米想要漫游。这就是非二元身份的魅力所在，也是乘坐露营车四处旅行的吸引力所在。是的，我们从3000平方英尺的
house to the two bedroom, to the one bedroom, to the studio, and she's almost to the pop-tent on the beach. I draw the line there. No, no. No pop-tents on the beach. And that's how we leave them, Jamie flowing like water and sandy, the level ground nearby. Debates of Agenda quickly produce vitriol, anger, and contempt.
房子一路搬到两居室、一居室、单间公寓，她现在几乎快搬到海滩上的简易帐篷里了。我在那儿画了一条界限。不，不。海滩上绝不搭简易帐篷。这就是我们离开他们时的状态，杰米如水般流动，而桑迪则是附近平坦的地面。关于性别的辩论总是迅速引发刻薄、愤怒和蔑视。
The folks who think biology determines gender roll their eyes at people who think culture is important. Proponents of culture accuse the biology people of being sexist. This is what happened after that Google memo went public. Everyone quickly took sides, we slotted people into groups, even if they didn't want membership in those groups. The former Google engineer, James Daymore, was embraced by ideologues on the alt-right, by groups that were critical of diversity.
那些认为生物学决定性别的人，对那些认为文化重要的人翻白眼。文化论的支持者则指责生物学派的人性别歧视。在谷歌备忘录公开后，情况正是如此。每个人迅速站队，我们将人们归入各种群体，即使他们并不想加入这些群体。前谷歌工程师詹姆斯·达莫尔（James Daymore）受到了极右翼思想家以及那些批评多元化群体的团体的拥护。
He said he wanted no part of their causes. As for Jamie Shoe, there are plenty of people who don't see Jamie as a conciliator or someone who occupies a middle ground. They see Jamie as someone who undermines the hard-earned victories of people who have long suffered disrespect. Jamie thinks that if people are both male and female, it isn't right for a transgender woman who's still partly a man in Jamie's, to have access to women's bathrooms. For the same reason, Jamie also thinks transgender women shouldn't be competing in athletic
他说他不想参与他们的任何事业。至于杰米·舒普，有许多人并不把杰米视为调解人或占据中间立场的人。他们视杰米为破坏那些长期遭受不尊重的人们来之不易的胜利成果的人。杰米认为，如果人们既是男性又是女性，那么对于一个在杰米看来仍然部分是男人的跨性别女性来说，去使用女性洗浴室是不合适的。出于同样的原因，杰米也认为跨性别女性不应该与其他女性一起参加竞技体育
competitions with other women. That said, there's a lesson to be taken from Jamie's story and from our larger debates about gender. When I first became a science journalist many years ago, I heard a phrase that stuck with me. Nature doesn't have edges. Humans like to think there is a clear demarcation between one species and the next, between one gender and the next, between one season and the next.
比赛。话虽如此，从杰米的故事以及我们关于性别的宏大辩论中，确实可以吸取一些教训。多年前我刚成为一名科学记者时，我听到过一句话，让我铭记至今。大自然没有边缘。人类喜欢认为一个物种和下一个物种之间、一个性别和下一个性别之间、一个季节和下一个季节之间存在着清晰的分界线。
But when you look closely, these categories get blurry, especially at the boundary between category A and category B. So many of our quarrels about gender come down to this. There are really ways of saying the categories I see and believe are better than the ones you see and believe. To the extent we will ever have progress on these debates, we may all need to get more comfortable with blurriness. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Gabriella Saldevia and Raina Cohen, and
但当你仔细观察时，这些分类变得模糊了，尤其是在A类和B类之间的边界上。我们关于性别的许多争论归根结底都在于此。它们实际上是在说“我看到并相信的分类比你看到并相信的分类更好”的方式。就我们在这些辩论中取得任何进展而言，我们可能都需要更能适应这种模糊性。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、加布里埃拉·萨尔德维亚（Gabriella Saldevia）和雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）制作，并由
edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Maggie Penman, René Clarre and Parth Shah. We had original music by Ramteen Arableui. NPR's Vice President for Programming and Audience Development is Anja Grunman. Special thanks to Phil Corbett of the podcast Van Sounds for helping us with our interview of Jamie and Sandy Schoo. Our unsung heroes this week are Emily Dagger, Sai Sykes and Andrew Hayden. Emily and Sai and Andrew have helped Shepherd Hidden brain from a podcast to a radio show,
塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）、勒内·克拉尔（René Clarre）和帕斯·沙阿（Parth Shah）。我们的原创音乐由拉姆蒂恩·阿拉布鲁伊（Ramteen Arableui）创作。NPR负责节目编排与听众发展的副总裁是安娅·格伦曼（Anja Grunman）。特别感谢播客“范之声”（Van Sounds）的菲尔·科尔伯特（Phil Corbett）协助我们采访杰米和桑迪·舒普。我们本周的无名英雄是艾米莉·达格（Emily Dagger）、赛·赛克斯（Sai Sykes）和安德鲁·海登（Andrew Hayden）。艾米莉、赛和安德鲁帮助将“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain）从一个播客推进为一个广播节目，
relaunched last week on more than 100 stations nationwide. Emily kept us on track throughout the process, while Sai and Andrew spread word about the show throughout the public radio ecosystem. All three of them are walking testaments to professionalism, for example as a fan of the Dallas Cowboys, Sai somehow managed to ignore the fact that I support the Philadelphia Eagles. Thanks Emily, Andrew and Sai for going above and beyond the call of duty. If you like this show, please share it with a friend
该节目于上周在全国100多家电台重新上线。艾米莉在整个过程中让我们保持进度，而赛和安德鲁则在公共广播生态系统中传播有关该节目的消息。他们三人都是专业精神的活生生证明，例如作为达拉斯牛仔队的球迷，赛竟然设法忽略了我支持费城老鹰队的事实。感谢艾米莉、安德鲁和赛超越职责要求的付出。如果你喜欢这个节目，请与朋友分享
where on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram. By the way, one of today's guests, neuroscientist Lease Elliott, has offered to answer follow-up questions about gender. So if you have questions, please send an email to hiddenbrainatnpr.org. We'll choose a few by Wednesday, October 11th, and we'll post Leigh's video responses on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram by the weekend. That email again is hiddenbrainatnpr.org. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上分享。顺便说一句，今天的嘉宾之一、神经科学家莉斯·艾略特（Lease Elliott）已主动提出回答有关性别的后续问题。所以如果你有问题，请发送电子邮件至 hiddenbrain@npr.org。我们将在10月11日（星期三）之前挑选几个问题，并在周末前将莉斯的视频回复发布在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上。再次说明邮箱地址是 hiddenbrain@npr.org。我是香卡·韦丹坦（Shankar Vedantum），这里是NPR。本集目前尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。